[Music]
hey there everyone just wanted to do a
shorter video for a change i'm still
working on bigger projects such as the
aftermath of the calamity and my
personal skyward sword review but these
will take a while to complete it's a lot
of work and on top of that i'm taking a
two week summer break just so i can you
know enjoy some free time away from the
computer and away from building chicken
coops the chickens are doing fine by the
way today i want to take a quick look at
a topic which has intrigued me ever
since i became aware of it though i must
be clear that although i did find this
on my own without anyone telling me
about it i am definitely not the first
to make this connection for instance one
of my discord mods cuckoo lover recently
made an in-depth video about the
possible symbolism and connections to
spirituality we might see in breath of
the wild too another video i highly
recommend watching if you're interested
in this topic is a video made by
nintendo black crisis about the ancient
cistern which besides talking about the
dungeon itself also presents a lot of
knowledge on buddhist traditions and
symbolism i'll put links to these two
videos in the description so keep in
mind i'm not trying to take credit for
anything i'm just here to present this
finding to those who may have missed it
so you may remember these weird statues
that we found in the breath of the wild
2 trailer prior to finishing skyward
sword myself i referred to these statues
as well as the shapes on this new golem
creature in the trailer of breathtaking
as pine cones or well pinecone things to
be exact but it has since become clear
to me that these are most likely not
pine cones but instead they are lotus
flowers to some this may seem trivial i
mean it's just a decoration right but
the lotus flower symbolism seen here
could actually be a very important clue
as to what we can expect from the sequel
to breath of the wild the significance
of the lotus flower cannot be
understated as it has direct connections
to something that people have been
trying to piece together ever since this
year's e3 namely what are these floating
islands why are they here where did they
come from why have they remained
invisible up until now and what will
their role be in the new game there have
been plenty of ideas about these
floating landmasses ever since we first
saw them some think it's similar to
skyloft where a magic cloud barrier
created by goddess hylia prevents people
from seeing this world above the clouds
even when the sky is clear others think
it might be the sacred realm or that we
didn't see these islands before because
breath of the wild 2 will take place in
a different time period there's no
shortage of speculation here one idea
which i have increasingly become a
supporter of is that this area of the
game is somehow connected to the spirit
realm a place where higher beings like
spirit guardians and perhaps even the
spirits of those who passed on reside
it's been made clear on many occasions
that a place like this exists in the
zelda universe in fact we visited a
location like this in skyward sword here
they are called silent realms and phi
makes it clear that these are the
domains of the spirits a place where the
living are not welcome unless given
special privilege by the gods or goddess
hylia in this case this is also where
the significance of the lotus flower
immediately becomes apparent in buddhism
the lotus among other things represents
purity and enlightenment and in skyward
sword it is used to represent the
spiritual growth link undergoes as well
as a way to justify this collectathon
but that's beside the point whenever
link enters the silent realm an orb will
emerge from his chest which then
manifests into a flower which is very
similar to the spirit orbs in breath of
the wild the spirit vessel as it is
referred to needs to be filled up
completely after which the flower at the
top will close creating a similar shape
to the one we see in the breath of the
wild 2 trailer the reason i initially
didn't make the connection between the
lotus flower and this shape is because
it's missing the plume at the top you
know where the petals come together so
that's why i called it a pinecone
instead but one quick glance at places
like the ancient cistern shows that this
plume doesn't have to be there as we see
plenty of lotus depictions that don't
have this feature either it's clear that
out of all zelda titles skyward sword is
the game which has the closest
connection to breath of the wild in
terms of its motifs symbolism as well as
the overall references placed in the
game like the springs goddess statues
dragon spirits forgotten temple just to
name a few so it's no surprise that the
sequel 2 will continue this trend as it
is still set in the same world as its
predecessor spirits are once again a
common occurrence in breath of the wild
the koroks elemental dragons lord of the
mountain great fairies and horus god
melania are all classified as spirit
beings they are also invisible to most
people with the exception of certain
chosen individuals like link as well as
young children it's implied that this
has something to do with the purity of
one soul in buddhism as well as
shintoism the age at which one loses its
innocence is said to be around 12 years
old after this point all humans become
impure and will need to purify
themselves we see something like this
play out in skyward sword as well zelda
needs to purify herself inside the
springs in order to become a suitable
vessel for the goddess and link needs to
grow his spirit in order to access the
sacred flames as well as make himself
ready to wield the full triforce the
fact that we see lotus depictions within
the sky realm of breath of the wild 2
almost certainly hints that the skies
he's traversing are more than just some
floating islands above the clouds but in
fact closely tied to the world of
spirits so another dimension altogether
which also explains why we don't see the
islands from the surface and as many
have pointed out this is further evident
from the strange portals the dragons use
to make their exit it's amazing to me
that the zelda team implemented details
like these into the game as it really
makes you feel like the story events of
the sequel were planned and purposely
hinted at all along i don't know if this
is the case but if it is props to them
as of right now it's unclear what the
goal of link's trip to the sky realm is
and to me this is very exciting it could
have something to do with the triforce
or at the very least the triforce of
courage since link from breath of the
wild is one of only a few incarnations
of link who as of right now has not
obtained the triforce of courage at any
point in his career as a hero he is
recognized as a true hero by mong mas
koshia as well as zelda herself but the
holy relic has eluded him thus far
obviously this wasn't necessary in
breath of the wild seeing as calamity
ganon wasn't a real entity but a mere
ghost created by malice i mean even the
master sword wasn't crucial to defeating
him which already raised a lot of
suspicion in breath of the wild too
however it seems link and zelda will be
dealing with the source of malice and
the true form of the demon king hence
obtaining the triforce or at the very
least the piece of courage might be the
motivation to travel to the heavenly
realm alternatively it could be that
link has been corrupted by malice with
his body and soul now tainted and impure
from his affliction he may need to
cleanse himself by entering the spirit
realm it could even explain the absence
of the master sword as it may have
rejected him now that he's been
corrupted by evil another option and yep
i'm gonna have to mention the zonai
again they might have something to do
with it their sudden disappearance could
mean that they have all died and passed
on to the afterlife if the zonai who are
described as having been powerful magic
wielders somehow possessed the key or
the knowledge to ganondorf's defeat be
it the triforce of courage or some other
powerful ability this could be the
reason why link has to travel to the
spirit realm as it could be the only way
to obtain this power or knowledge by
gaining an audience with the spirits of
these ancient warriors zelda's
disappearance or even possible death as
dark as that would be could also have
something to do with it it's not like
zelda's spirit hasn't been separated
from her body before you know what that
would totally explain why we hear
zelda's lullaby at the end of the
trailer it is unmistakably her theme but
instead of the usual flute or harp the
theme is played using the same
instrument as the one we hear for the
dragon deities which as stated before
are spirits
[Music]
[Music]
maybe this signifies that zelda's spirit
is trapped in the spirit world or the
underworld as she is seen falling down
so maybe link travels to the spirit
world to somehow free her soul some
might also be pleased to know that
although the champions and king rome
passed on to the afterlife at the end of
breath the wild the possible existence
of a spirit world in breath while 2
could mean that we will see them again
after all maybe not with a very big role
this time around and probably only in
spirit form yet again but still there
are plenty of possibilities and of
course if you have your own ideas don't
hesitate to share them down in the
comments a good discussion is always
welcome who knows what we might find in
this other realm it's been long since
revealed that breath of the wild was
initially supposed to feature a
minish-like race of tiny creatures link
could interact with the minish last seen
in minish cap share a lot of traits with
that of the koroks in that they are
invisible to most people and mostly show
themselves to children alone the realm
of the minish is also said to reside
close to the heavens and we even see a
symbol very similar to that of vati who
is revealed to have been a minish
himself not saying vati will make an
appearance in breath while too though
that would be awesome but it could be
more than just a reference and yet
another clue that ties the sky from
breath to wall 2 to some higher plane of
existence and that's pretty much it for
this one again this was more of a stray
thought than a well-constructed theory
but i gotta give myself a break once in
a while as stated at the beginning
bigger stuff is on the way but it will
take a while before they see the light
of day right now i'm focused on only two
things taking a break and going on a
nice trip and playing metroid dread
which i'm very excited for i also want
to apologize for the lack of streams
lately i've been having some very
annoying technical issues the biggest of
which being my internet shutting down at
random i've contacted my provider about
this and they are looking into it but
apparently it's not just my internet but
the entire block is having this problem
so until this is resolved i won't be
able to stream properly so i hope you
can bear with me as always thank you so
much for watching the support the kind
words and the comments the whole thing i
cannot stress enough how much this all
means to me you guys make my day time
and time again and i'm humbled that i
can do this stuff for a living your
likes comments feedback and all that
good jazz not only motivates me but also
teaches me all sorts of things i didn't
know and that is worth so much to me a
special shout out goes to my patreons
and members as always as well as my
discord and streaming mods you guys are
the best and i'm continuously amazed by
your support your hard work your
feedback just everything you do also
please give a warm welcome to jennifer
butler gamesmiths and roseret17 for
joining my crew as well as a special
thanks to barky doggo who has been
extremely generous with extra donations
over the past months also keep an eye
out for another special thanks which i
will probably film in person someone
sent me an amazing gift and i want to
highlight it but so far i just haven't
had the time for it so banoon if you are
listening i will cover it soon again
thank you so much to each and every one
of you and that is all for now i hope to
see you in the next video this is dawn
signing off and have a good one
[Music]
you